[Applaudissements]
je vais demander à chacun des
parlementaires qui brandit une pancarte
de bien vouloir cesser immédiatement
cela est contraire à notre règlement
on ne peut pas faire de Paris sur
l'avenir de nos retraites cette réforme
est nécessaire aussi sur le fondement de
l'article de 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 modifier par
l'amendement de coordination communiquer
à l'Assemblée nationale
on est déçu parce qu'on voulait aller au
vote on voulait aller au vote on voulait
que que la représentation nationale
puisse s'exprimer et que chacun aussi
prenne ses responsabilités parce que si
nous au modem nous pensons que cette
réforme est difficile nous pensons aussi
qu'elle était nécessaire pour les
équilibres financiers et pour la
pérennité du régime par répartition
employer l'autoritarisme comme ils sont
en train de le faire pour passer en
force une réforme des retraites dont
personne ne veut et sur lequel avait de
faiblesse suprême ils sont obligés
d'utiliser le 49-3
est un signe qu'ils enfoncent le pays
tout entier dans une crise de régime et
nous le disons à toutes celles et ceux
qui se mobilisent dans le pays rien
n'est fini et à ceux qui au pouvoir
aujourd'hui Sam le chaos dans ce pays
nous répondrons évidemment par la
censure mais là on l'espèce il y avait
une majorité de députés contre ces
textes une majorité de Français contre
ce texte et ils font passer ce texte de
force
c'est donc incontestablement une
dénaturation de notre fonctionnement
démocratique pour faire passer une
réforme dont chacun admet qu'elle est
brutale injuste il faut censurer ce
gouvernement donc non seulement nous
déposerons une motion de censure mais
nous voterons l'ensemble des motions de
censure qui vont être déposés et je
pense qu'elles seront relativement
nombreuses
[Musique]